you're the only person i think i've ever
seen who has built a pc worse than joey
really oh well thank god thank you i i
said daddies was like i'm gonna build pc
is it hard and i'm like no no it should
be fine yeah i i've struggled before in
the past yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you can do it it's hard i've been there
and so
thank you one day dinos texts me and
he's like connor sos literally sos
he's like i need help and i'm yeah why
what's wrong he's like oh the pc i think
i've broken it or it won't work right i
don't know what to do the processor i go
over to his house right first thing i
see is that like nothing is plugged in
correctly
only like why are you scaring me
it is it's daunting yeah yeah i'm like
wear plugs into where like yeah i get it
and so like i find one problem okay
let's let's fix this down and as i fix
it i find another problem
and then okay well let's fix it and then
as i'm gonna fix this i find out like
the motherboard isn't even screwed in
i was just like sitting there it's just
like it's just floating it was four
screwed in so the motherboard typically
is like nine screws right yeah yeah
sized one he'd only screwed in six and
one one half of the motherboard it
wouldn't work
so you could you could flip it
and
and
it
like lifted up and i'm like bro
you've got like one month out of this pc
and so we have to take out the home even
i know that you need to screw up yeah
okay but it was like hanging up so i
thought i was like oh it's a different
type of case maybe like maybe it's
supposed to hang like that but but then
conor came in he put like a little
washer in it and then it increased the
size stands off yeah and i was like oh
that's how you screw it yeah i just
couldn't believe it i was like this pc
it's you know it's going to last a tiny
king
is it was it was it because you were
watching was it because you were
watching every tutorial is too sweet
so he missed the part where they were
screaming it's like oh i guess it just
screws in like that right the problem
with the motion tutorials is that
they're like i have a different
motherboard in a different graphics card
it's a different screw because you're
building it for emily right so yeah and
you want a pink case in this case
right garbage it's probably the worst pc
case i've ever worked with the graphics
card had like one millimeter of
clearance
like it like was that the only pink you
could find in japan i think so oh okay
well is it pink pink anything related
it's always a miracle it fit
is a miracle it all fit
and then there's like no room in the
case and he texted me he's like why are
the fans so loud i'm like because
there's no air yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like type of ventilation you've got a
3080 in there and like like one one bag
of air
hey but it's fast
yeah yeah right
it works now i guess
but yeah i know that feel it's scary i
guess like you know since it is your
first time moving to a like basically a
completely different country like is
there like anything do you have like a
bucket list of things you want to do
still i'm sure you've like ticked off
all the food stuff right yeah for the
most part
and you know like company and [ __ ] like
yeah like is there like anything you
want to like i want to go to certain
place or i want to do this certain thing
i couldn't do in the us
or you just like i've been the answer
now
hell yeah we're going to take you to
onsen man
let's go
yeah yeah yeah yeah you'll literally get
over it
what is that look you're like okay get
over it in like 15 seconds yeah yeah
i've seen each other's dig many times
i'm done i'm ready
when i took these boys on onsen the
first time we were just like let's just
look at each other's dicks yeah just get
it out of the way just like just slap it
around yeah just wait noodle fight for
[Laughter]
i think you're really i mean you love
taking baths already right so like yeah
i [ __ ] love the onsen yeah it's just
like taking a bath with your bros yeah
in a massive bath i'm down bro i'm down
[Laughter]
it sucks though because like we can't
take you to like uh the one i took these
guys to yeah it's like close down now
there's like another one somewhere else
but it's really far away oh really
in tokyo not out just outside of tokyo
oh okay okay i was gonna ask do you have
any piece of advice for anyone who does
want to move abroad anything you've
learned on this thing yeah because
because you you you like more than
anyone else i've met have just has just
jumped into the deep end yeah without
even like without even like dipping your
toes in at all well that's just because
of geeks plus right it's just
no but like but i mean like you know i
i'm not gonna lie like i probably
wouldn't have the balls to just be like
yeah i'm just going to move to this
country i've never been to yeah and just
like start living there like that takes
a lot i think you just have to be done
you're like i'm done like
i gotta go or dumb i'm done i'm done
just be
yeah i mean like if you visit it's still
hard to get like the feel for how it
actually actually live there like
visiting japan and living here is like
two completely different yeah
maybe that's a blessing i don't know
yeah yeah maybe it is maybe it is i
don't know i i enjoy it a lot yeah i i
have no regrets
i was worried when that
i was like yeah you should come over and
you're like yeah let's do it i was like
oh my god what if he hates it yeah if he
doesn't i was i was really worried that
you were just gonna get gonna get like
the biggest culture shock of like your
life which because you've never
experienced anything like this before
but seems like you're really having a
good time because for a lot of people
it's like it's so far off from what
they're used to yeah it's just that's
what makes it fun though right but yeah
yeah yeah but a lot of people can't take
that right a lot of people are like no
this is like too much yeah this is like
too much yeah yeah because a lot i think
there's a lot of people like
what
because there's a lot of people who are
like yeah i love traveling but then when
they actually travel there you know end
up going to mcdonald's and they like try
and like seek comfort in a different
country in a different culture i think
well having like
you know people i know yeah yeah oh yeah
immensely yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely if you guys weren't here it'd
just be like it would be a struggle yeah
i'd like what do i do like
back in the basement then i guess
but in japan
very very fortunate yeah because like
even like small things like i remember
like i've met plenty of people who are
just like man the foods here are amazing
and you meet them like a month in you're
like
do people eat rice with every meal every
meal i love that stuff yeah i'll ever
get tired of japanese food yeah when i
came here on vacation i got really tired
of japanese food really yeah when i
lived here i didn't i don't know why i
think maybe it's because while you're on
vacation you were seeking out japanese
food right because you're kind of in
that mentality of like well i don't get
the opportunity yeah yeah yeah it's food
even like the fried chicken didn't quite
have like the the quite the greasy i do
i do miss like
some american [ __ ] like yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah of course like that's
that's gonna happen but i think that's
the cool thing about like especially
tokyo right is that there's literally
every type of cuisine yeah level out
there right yeah this is pretty crazy
yeah yeah there's very few cuisines that
i'm just like i can't get that hill like
maybe i'm like craving like a specific
dish that i can't get here but for the
most part you can get anything here in
terms of like good food and it's gonna
be good service and good service service
yeah yeah robots yeah only robots
no they're not human i don't respect
them they give me my food their soul is
gone
like actually